When I first learned about Iran
like most people I was exposed
exclusively to stuff like this:
But as I started to look closer, I started
to see a much different
Iran then what the Islamic Republic
regime represents.
The reaction in Iran to the news about a
potential deal
is a good example of what I'm talking
about. Immediately following the news
of this deal with the West,
people lined up to greet foreign
ministers Zarif as he returned from
Switzerland.
They spent all night celebrating the
potential lifting of sanctions and
closer ties with the West.
So what's going on here?
Is Iran this? Or is it this?
A while back I reached out to twenty five Iranians on Facebook.
These were people between the ages of 21
and 35 who lived all over the country.
I started following them and realizing that
they were totally normal people.
They posted cat videos and took pictures of
their food
and talked about clothes and sports and took plenty of selfies.
I never once saw a dogmatic the
religious posts and I certainly never
saw anything anti-western
I started to realize that there is a big
difference between what
I had studied about this regime
and what the people were actually like.
These were people who were born after  the 1979 revolution.
They were not a part of the emotion and
their zeal that brought about the
current Iran and all of its hostilities towards the West.
Instead they grew up in an environment of
increase in seclusion from the world
on one hand while gaining huge access to
the world through the internet on the other hand
So in today's Iran people are less
likely to hate Americans.
In my effort to befriend Iranians on
Facebook,
I don't have a single person reject my
friend request.
In fact most have them sent me a message
telling me how happy they were to
connect
and how they would love to talk more
about our different cultures.
Politics wasn't a big part of this
conversation.
So, no matter how easy it is to label
Iran is this
pariah nation bent on hard-line
religious fundamentalism,
remember that while they're definitely
supporters that ideology,
there is a whole other side to this country
that we rarely see.
Most Iranians are normal people living
normal lives.
They want to connect, they want to feel
safe, and
they want peace as much as you and I do.
That's something I think we can afford
to talk about a little bit more.